well I think we've been surprised
certainly in a lot of the work that
we've done but particularly so in the
national park by the amazing diversity
of the story this is not just a top-down
history I mean most people think
American history is just a series of
presidential administrations punctured
by wars and and that gives you a fairly
you know I suppose superficial handle on
things but it's much more complicated
than that and the bottom-up view that
we've always tried to adopt delivers you
much more complexity and undertow it
allows you to penetrate more fully into
the the number one sub theme of American
life race born as we were under the idea
that all men are created equal but the
guy who wrote that sentence owned 100
other people never saw the contradiction
never saw the hypocrisy and more
important never saw fit in his lifetime
to free any of those people and set in
motion and American narrative that in
almost every way is constantly bumping
up against this question of race the
Civil War the most important event in
our history wouldn't have happened had
slavery not existed in a country that
was proclaiming to the world this new
idea of individual liberty so that's
there and diversity naturally occurring
diversity is an important part of the
films that we make and in this one to
understand that the Buffalo Soldiers the
celebrated African American cavalry men
of the late nineteenth and early
twentieth century were the first Park
defenders in California's Sierra
Mountains at Yosemite and General Grant
what was then called General Grant
national park in Sequoia National Park
and what an amazing phenomenon that in
the first decade of the 20th century a
decade by the way when more
african-americans were lynched than any
other time in our history that
african-americans might be telling other
Americans what to do in a national park
was interesting and that complements the
top down or the more top-down story of
John Muir this scottish-born naturalist
beaten by his father until he memorized
the entire New Testament and
three-quarters of the Old Testament
could find a new faith in nature that
was utterly American utterly
transcendental therefore in wild nature
that he could dispose of the dogmatic
devotion that the
European tradition worshipping
cathedrals and representatives of God
meant and could free himself and his
countrymen his adopted country men and
women by sharing a new faith in the
mountains and he is the most important
prophet of not just the national parks
but the idea behind the national parks
and that's why that's why we made the
film this is not a travelogue or a
nature film per se this is the history
of individuals and ideas and and we say
it's America's best idea knowing full
well it's provocative and challenging
but once you've started a country on the
idea of individual liberty you'd be
hard-pressed to find a better idea than
setting aside for the first time in
human history land not for kings or
noblemen of the rich but for everybody
and for all times we invented it it's an
utterly American idea and could have
only happened where people were
struggling to figure out how to govern
themselves however flawed that original
conception might have been
I finished a film on the civil war in
1990 and a couple years later I was back
at Gettysburg which is a national park
site walking across the lawn of the
visitors center with the superintendent
and I he scooped down at one point and
picked up a popsicle wrapper and waved
it in his face in my face and said it's
all your fault and what he meant was
that his attendance had gone up a
hundred two hundred three hundred
percent after my film on the civil war
and had stayed there so I guess what I
want is for every superintendent of
every national park unit and there's 392
to be mad at me because they've got
people coming and they don't know what
to do with him and that's already
happened all of the things I want have
already taken place we had a huge tens
of millions of viewers on public
television people are rearranging their
plans to go to the national parks and
that in and of itself without having a
specific political agenda will change
the agenda of the United States with
regard to parks the parks have undergone
years of neglect the previous
administration allowed upwards of eight
or nine billion dollars worth of
maintenance deferred maintenance to take
place and we now have to go back and
figure out where that money comes from
and how to bring the parks back up to
snuff and how to think about wild places
for the 21st century and that's a
challenge which i think the parks
reminded people that they were invested
in that you know you say you're working
on the national parks and it's like aha
it doesn't sound so cool and everybody's
assumes they've always been there they
haven't and therefore that threatens
them they assume the National Park
Service has always been there to take
care of them they haven't they don't
show up until 50 years into the
existence of the national parks and
therefore they're threatened and they
assume they'll always be there and if
people believe that then they are most
definitely threatened because once you
lose a place it's lost forever once
you've saved it the saving is like
Liberty itself and it requires a kind of
eternal vigilance and and I think that
what we did was help re instill some of
our fellow citizens with that sense of
the vigilance required and in that case
it's already a success and we've gotten
what we've